this is Meek Mill you sedated Nicki
Minaj but what you may not know is that
he's been in and out of jail for over a
decade Philly rapper Meek Mill has just
been sentenced to two to four years in
state prison ultimately his story's a
story of a broken system something much
bigger parole and probation are touted
to be substitutions for jail time their
intent is to keep people out of jail but
for millions of Americans that's just
not what's happening let's talk about
that
I'm sorry McKesson in this is truth be
told
it all started a decade ago in
Philadelphia no my name Meek Mill II
froze flames but I got that fire man
plumbers coming 2007 meek was arrested
the first time he was 19 officer showed
up at the house of meek was living he
had a search warrant that they got by
telling a judge that they see meek a day
earlier at make a drug deal and when
they served the warrant they say meek
pointed a gun at them and then ran away
ultimately he was arrested and they
found an unregistered gun on him now
meek denies the cops claims he says he
was unfairly targeted by the police and
Beno now here's a picture of meek after
he was arrested a side note the
arresting officer resna Graham later
wound up on a list compiled by the
Philadelphia District Attorney's Office
of cops who would deem so problematic
that even the prosecutors didn't want
them testifying in court now Meeks
lawyers have always maintained that the
cops got the wrong guy
back in 2007 in court a judge sentenced
me to jail on a range of charges
including drug and weapons violations
and this is how many years he on
probation in 2009 after six months in
jail he was paroled a house arrest had
things ended there meek would have
gotten off from probation in 2017 but
things didn't end when he was paroled
and put on probation probation is handed
down when a person is first sentenced
and is served either after jail term or
instead of one well your probation
you're not behind bars but you have to
check in with the court sometimes for a
very long time it's basically the
criminal justice system's way of saying
we're gonna keep a close eye on you
probation sentences can stretch on for
years and involve ownerís supervision
requirements like random drug tests
travel restrictions frequent check-ins
with the court in even check ins with
judges a person might not be behind bars
but on probation they're just one
slip-up away I'm going back now keeping
people out of jail is the right goal to
have the problem here is it the way we
administer probation often backfires
this is me story in 2011 as
mix tapes were taking off and they were
great it's what led to his career he
felt a couple drug tests it was given a
probation violation
the court was miring him in other ways
too meek needed the approval of a judge
to even travel now just think about it
he's a rapper he's performing all over
the place he had to get the judges
approval at all the venues for a tour
that's pretty intense now he's up top
he received travel violations in 2013
2014 and 2015 that probation sentence
that would have been over by now
it's now up to 2022 last year on a court
approved trip meat got into an
altercation at the airport in San Luis
mill was arrested for a scuffle at the
st. Louis Airport what's up me target of
pigs he was like nah and I guess I'm
doing this group got mad oh I'm at work
so I'm just defending myself
I know I swung first then he got
community service in st. Louis but the
court back in Philly guess what happened
you got it and credited him with another
probation violation and last August cops
in New York's on Instagram being a bleep
dirtbike in May arrested him for
reckless endangerment
it was another violation despite all
that Meeks career had exploded he had
two albums certified gold and one
platinum and in 2016 he won the
Billboard Music Award for top rap album
he'd become one of the most recognizable
rappers on the planet of course for all
the highs on meek none mattered more
than those of a certain judge in
Philadelphia judge Jenice Brinkley judge
Janice Brinkley judge Jenice Brinkley
welcome to judge Franklin thank you very
much I'm so happy to be here meet judge
Anissa Brinkley now she's a complicated
figure in this entire story
this woman's connection goes back to the
very beginning and it underscores the
way that a single judge can have a huge
impact on one person's case like in this
one
the judge who Mills lawyers accused of
having a personal vendetta against the
rapper Meeks attorneys are now trying to
get her a move from the case they
claimed her to brinkley has been way to
invest it in their client for starters
she showed up a meek restoring community
service to check up on him this is not a
normal thing judges don't just like
randomly go around the community service
and see what's happening she also
ordered him to take etiquette classes
and by the way his lawyers have said
she's done some other really odd things
too for instance
they've said in court documents if she
asked me to record an updated version of
the boy Simon ballad on bended knee
apparently so she could hear a name
[Music]
they've also claimed she asked him to
leave his management company jay-z's Roc
Nation and instead hire a local
Philadelphia manager now judge Brinkley
denies these allegations and said
there's no evidence that true she says
she stands by her original decision to
sentence him to prison saying she quote
committed no error and she's right
there's technically no error right now
the way he's been dragging the system is
the way the system currently works but
it doesn't have to be the way that we
build the system that his case alone is
an indictment of how the system is
functioning it's worth noting meek it
racked up not a single new criminal
commission just to provision violations
in other words nothing that would ever
on its own earn several years in prison
now look the worst part of this case is
that Meeks story is decidedly not
extraordinary or even unusual we just
know him because he's famous but there
are thousands out there with similar
stories the US Department of Justice
said Pennsylvania and Micah's from have
one of the largest probation populations
of any state in the country about a
third of Pennsylvania state prisoners
are probationers or parolees sent back
to prison today we've got nearly this
many people in this country caught up in
the system of so-called mass supervision
and guess who's being supervised in 2014
a study of probation of four american
municipalities found that black
probationers at greater odds in anyone
else of having their probation room now
have more african-americans under
criminal supervision than all the slaves
back in the 1850s and for what many
times it's for the little slip-ups often
like meat mill probationers have merely
violated the terms of supervision
incarcerated in other words for
technical violations the good news is
that some states are pushing reform
efforts for instance these states are
looking to improve their probation
systems Meeks case helps put the problem
into clearer focus now we're smart about
it we'll use
Milas case to think deeper about
alternatives to incarceration to think
about how to change probation so it's
not just like a pathway back to jail you
have the power to work to change this at
the local and state level wherever you
are